all right let's close things out with
one more feel-good story to brighten
your day hopefully this is what i'm
liking
[Music]
earlier this hour we had the
groundbreaking cast from the movie coda
hanging out there's another actress
that's deaf helping change norms in the
industry in fact she's one of the very
first deaf actors ever to be credited
for her role doing sign over work
alongside her voiceover counterpart so
you can see her in season six of
madagascar a little wild on peacock and
hulu hmm
wait it's in his hand
i wonder what he's saying to that little
kid huh dave is telling she leaves that
balloon is as big as his sister's head
[Music]
he's not wrong how did you learn sign
language dee's been teaching me
now shaylee's saying i like your cards
and dave just said wanna trade oh
what
let's say hi to 12 year old shaylee
mansfield and her interpreter
what's up shaylee hi
so shaylee how cool is this like what
does it mean for you to get a roll like
this
well
i just can't even put it into words how
it felt to get this role
because my entire life ever since i was
a little girl
i've been a big fan of animated movies
television shows
and i would watch all of these programs
and
i just was addicted i would tell you i
couldn't stop
but i constantly had a thought kelly
like hey
where's a deaf character on this
animated program
i want to see a deaf character on my
screen somebody who's like me somebody
who has life experiences like me
and it wasn't until this project came
about
where i was so excited to be involved
and this character was really the one i
had been dreaming about my whole life
and i'm so grateful to dreamworks
and this was my first voiceover credit
or sign over credit which was very
exciting and it was also like my first
role being a sign over actor so it was
so great for two really important
reasons
many people think oh the character on
madagascar a little wild is just deaf
but no she's a kid
she's so good at trading cards and she
also hates to lose and i can relate to
that personally because no one knows but
i'm going to tell you right now i hate
losing too
i don't know many people that just love
losing like
thank you so much shaylee
congratulations on this and i wish you
nothing but success i think that's a
really awesome idea incorporating more
deaf characters especially in things
like you know my little kids and i'm 39
years old and i still love and watch
animation i love animated films i think
they're so important they have so many
important messages and they're just fun
you know as a family to sit down and
watch so i hope that someone is
listening right now and does incorporate
that thank you so much and i'm liking
your post right now
and that's not all our season long
partner pilot pin makers of friction the
go to eraseable pin of the kelly
clarkson show want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly just like you ma'am
so they're going to give you a thousand
dollars just because you're red
[Laughter]
are you serious
what oh my god oh my gosh thank you so
much you are more than welcome that was
an amazing response i love that response
thank you so much shaylee
[Music]